the fact that it's so common and that
nobody talks about it is so
crazy to me because it's a big thing you
know
whether it's infertility or whether it's
losses
i mean it's really insane and it's
really sad and lonely
i guess that big voice in my head is
like well why do you want to talk about
something sad when it's something
happening but like
because they go hand in hand and it's
also really important for me to
to show people that it does happen i had
to work with the doctor
and it happened and it's something that
people should talk about
because it it really takes some of the i
don't know
it just it just helps away the weight
yeah the weight
perfect yeah how are you feeling today
i'm feeling good
society tells you to like be so quiet
about it for
like three months and that's a long time
i can't keep a secret for
a day so it's um it's really
just like very uplifting to talk about
it and to have it be celebrated
so it's beautiful i feel like i'm really
like get really really sick in this
pregnancy i'm always just like
it's okay like it's okay it's it's the
baby i find i love it i love it thank
you while elle isn't due
until the fall she and country superstar
miranda lambert just delivered their own
musical baby the single drunk and i
don't want to go home
what was it like working with her on
this record
she's such a superstar so when we were
recording it didn't take that long
i showed up with i think six bottles of
liquor
just to like make it so that we weren't
nervous
yeah wait what kind of liquor what are
we talking like well she loves
she loves tito's and so i brought her a
handle of tito's
it was awesome
i know that you're getting married in
real life so
would you incorporate any of these looks
into your real wedding
you know what's funny i felt so
beautiful in that ridiculous wedding
dress
because daniel my fiance played the
groom in the video
we like it like felt like our wedding
day because
we're probably gonna have like a white
trash wedding anyways
but i i think i'll wear like a
more subtle gown probably